all right
all right all right we're waiting for a
couple people to get in here real quick
go ahead and smash the like button so
more people on youtube can find this
content make sure that you are
subscribed to the channel
and also go ahead and subscribe
to the letter that i write every single
morning to over 50 000
investors pompletter.com
i see everyone joining if you
are joining let me know where you are
tuning in
from all right guys all right all right
so
here's the deal let's get started with
what's been going on in the economic
crisis
if we go back to uh really last year
what we saw was a situation
where we had a great
kind of late stage economy there was
stock market all-time highs there were
businesses
that were growing really nicely
but we started to see a couple of
warning signs and those warning signs
really were things like inverted yield
curves
gyrations in the repo markets a high
number of ceos
leaving the companies and stepping down
and so i think what we ended up
really kind of feeling was the market
was frothy all of a sudden we get a
public health
crisis or the pandemic that pandemic
ends up
forcing the governments around the world
and here in the united states
to mandate a government shutdown or
mandated shutdown so what that means is
everyone's got to go shelter in place
they need to um essentially not go to
work and so the velocity of money
drastically slowed
and that velocity of money was a really
big factor
uh for a while right is if you don't
have velocity of money then how can you
possibly have a
positive economic situation it becomes
very difficult to do
and so what we saw was when the velocity
of money slowed
now all of a sudden we get a situation
where it exposes the underlying issues
in the economy and so
let's just recap in about march the
second or third week of march we got
these
uh shelter-in-place orders since then we
have had over 55 million americans lose
their jobs
since then we have seen equity markets
they tanked
30 percent on average or approximately
we saw bitcoin dropped 50 in a single
day we saw gold go down 12 to 15
right all this crazy crazy chaos but as
soon as that stuff started to happen as
soon as asset prices started to sell off
in that liquidity crisis
we immediately saw the government and
the federal reserve step in
and they dipped back into the 2008
financial crisis playbook
and that playbook was to pump asset
prices to inject as much liquidity
as they possibly could into the economy
and so what you saw was two emergency
rate cuts right central banks only have
two tools to deal with economic
downturns
they cut interest rates twice in
emergency measures
all the way down to zero percent so we
had a zero percent uh rate environment
they then decided to do multiple rounds
of monetary stimulus
totaling up to about three trillion
dollars give or take and so in 2008 2009
crisis we saw hundreds of billions
printed
this time we saw trillions printed and
so when you cut rates and you print a
bunch of money
what happens is we literally did an
about face
so those equities that had fallen 30
basically skyrocketed right they fell
off a cliff and then they turn around
they skyrocketed as all this
liquidity got injected into the market
not only was that equities though
gold went from down 12 to 15 to today
gold is up between 25 and 30 percent
bitcoin went down 50 in a single day now
it's up year to date over 60 right so
what you saw was that injection of
liquidity
ended up inflating asset prices at the
same time we saw some anomalies
right so take real estate for example in
the real estate market if there was a
recession and a pandemic most people
would expect real estate residential
real estate prices to fall off a cliff
right to drop drastically
but instead we saw something different
we saw the median home price in america
actually increase
why well there's a zero rate
environments there's cheap capital
flowing around so people are
incentivized to go borrow that capital
and buy new homes
uh and when they do that that increases
demand for new homes
at the same time there's a u.s housing
shortage every year about
200 to 250 000 homes aren't built that
need to be to keep up with demand
and so you have a housing shortage so
the supply side is uh less than we need
at the same time you have a drastic
increase in demand and so what you get
is you get a
drastic increase in price or an increase
in price and so that's what we saw in
the housing market so real estate was
strong
even though we were in a recession in
the pandemic we saw equities recover
we saw gold recover we saw bitcoin
recover um
and kind of we are in the situation
where we are today now
it's important to call out that right
now there is a
very very big disparity between what is
going on
in the financial markets and the
economic realities on the ground
right in one side of the world in the in
the wealthy side of the world
there are people who have made tens of
billions of dollars right the
billionaires
in america have made tens of billions of
dollars in some cases for a total of
almost uh or i think it's over now half
a trillion dollars
so the richest people in the united
states made over half a trillion dollars
so far during this pandemic
the poorest people have lost their jobs
many cases they can't pay their rent
they can't pay their credit cards and
they're suffering
so how is it that the rich get richer
the poor get poorer well it's because
the economic crisis
exposes the structural setup
of the global financial system and so
what is that right
this ultimately gets at what can you do
at home with your money
to benefit from economic chaos and
uncertainty
just like the billionaires and the
wealthy well
so we're clear this is not financial
advice this is merely an education
on how the financial system works and so
key is first of all you've got to
understand
how money works so when trillions and
trillions of dollars is printed
what that is doing is it is making each
individual dollar
less valuable right it's still one
dollar equals one dollar
but the value of a dollar is ultimately
determines what can you buy
so if for example a hundred dollars
could
um or let's say a thousand dollars could
buy you a computer
if the value of the dollar goes down
right the purchasing power goes down
it may now take you fifteen hundred
dollars to buy that same computer
if the value of the dollar was to
increase the purchasing power was to
increase
maybe now it'd only take five hundred
500 to buy that same computer
so the computer still does the exact
same thing it still
has the exact same value it had
previously it's just whether the dollar
is stronger or weaker what determines
whether you need more or less dollars to
buy that same computer
now this usually plays out over decades
so we don't really see it right about
two percent inflation
so over a very long period of time the
cost of things will
um go up but it's not seen on a
day-to-day basis
in the united states we have a pretty
disciplined monetary policy
where you do see it play out though is
investment assets
so again if you go back and you look at
in march of this year we saw asset
prices fall off a cliff
and then all of a sudden now we see
those asset prices having
you know skyrocketed back if you look
bitcoin at one point this year
was sitting at eight thousand and a
single day dropped under four thousand
dollars hit thirty eight hundred dollars
today it's trading at almost twelve
thousand over two hundred percent
increase in that asset liquidity is
being injected into this
uh economy at an incredible rate so what
does this mean for people at home
is ultimately what you have to do is you
have to understand
uh how to position yourself to benefit
rather than
suffer in this environment and so what
are the rich people doing
how are rich people making billions of
dollars
during a time when tens of millions of
americans have lost their job
it's simple the rule is very very simple
get out of cash and get into assets
why because the dollar is being devalued
systematically and intentionally by the
federal reserve
and people in the government in order to
increase
asset prices so this is a a rigged game
right what i mean by a rigged game is
that there are decisions being made
by elected officials and by federal
reserve officials
that says it is important for the
stability of our financial system
to ensure that financial asset prices
do not fall drastically we need to
inflate
those asset prices we need to pump
liquidity into the economy
we need to make sure that there's not a
liquidity crisis
and so when they do that those asset
prices are explode like we've seen
and so when you're sitting at home you
don't have to be a genius
right all you have to understand is
structurally what is happening
and then position yourself to benefit
rather than suffer
and then allow the market structure to
take over and so what most
wealthy people have done over the last
four to five months
is they have gone from holding cash to
buying stocks
buying precious metals buying real
estate and buying bitcoin
that's what they've done and why have
they done that yes they have conviction
they've done work on the individual
assets that they're buying right they've
got some thesis
as to why they should buy one over
another
but ultimately what's driving their
decision is the understanding that if i
hold a bunch of cash
that cash is going to be devalued and
asset prices are going to increase
so in most cases gold's value
has not changed from march to today
what is different about gold nothing
what's different is
the macro environment and the value of
the dollar
that's why gold's price price has
increased
right the value hasn't changed but the
price has changed
and the reason the price has changed is
because there was an increase in demand
for an asset that's harder to get than
something that's fully available
and also the dollars being devalued and
so you see the gold price go up
so what about real estate remember what
i said the value of the dollar
is decreasing and there's a shortage an
increase in demand because cheap capital
is available so what happened the median
home price for residential homes the
united states
went up look at stocks stocks
saw the dollar being devalued and they
saw an increase in demand because when
the stimulus checks went out
there's a bunch of data that shows that
a bunch of people who took the
quote-unquote free money
in the stimulus checks turned around and
put it into the stock market
stocks go up and so that is what
quote-unquote rich people are doing
they understand structurally how the
market works and they're positioning
themselves to benefit from it
and if you are sitting holding cash
you're going to get crushed
if you go back to 2008 2009 financial
crisis what we know
is that the official cpi numbers which
is a measure of inflation
never got above two percent but those
are the official numbers
that measure the consumer prices right
the goods
what we should be paying attention to is
two things there's one nuance
inflation does not hit every
socio-economic
um kind of basket or bucket equally so
the top 20
of people in the world they actually
experience very low levels of inflation
at all times
the bottom 20 of people can experience
very high levels of inflation
there are multiple studies that show um
and forecast that people in the bottom
twenty percent of populations
experience between six to ten percent
inflation coming out of 2008 2009
they live paycheck to paycheck and they
don't have a lot of investable assets
and so if you don't have investable
assets and you live paycheck to paycheck
then i think what ends up occurring is
you
are going to experience inflation at a
different level than people who have all
investable assets
right most rich people don't have a lot
of cash sitting around they're sitting
in financial investments those
investments appreciate over time
why is the stock market literally it
just looks like a 45 degree angle up
into the right
over decades how is that possible
well it's because it's not necessarily
that the stocks are getting more
valuable
it's the fact that the u.s dollar is
being systematically devalued
and the the price of those stocks are
increasing
because of inflation right if you
denominate the stock market in
gold stocks are down or
equal to 1971 1972.
if you denominate the stock market in
bitcoin stocks are down drastically
so it's all about a price is a numerator
and a denominator
and depending on what denominator you
use depends on your perspective as to
what gains in value and what decreases
in value
and the stock market although when you
zoom out
and you denominate in dollars it looks
like a 45 degree angle up into the right
kind of you've probably heard that
stocks uh appreciate on a
eight to nine percent compounded uh rate
annually
that's not necessarily because the
stocks are doing that it's because the
dollars being devalued
and so holding cash ends up being a
punishment
in the finance system we live in today
and so rich people
are not holding cash they get out of
cash and into investable assets
now many people will say wait a second i
don't have a lot of cash i don't have a
lot of
investment assets how can i go ahead and
take the little cash that i have
and get started today the first key is
there are
four key principles or four timeless
financial pieces
of guidance that you should listen to
and they're timeless
because they've been true for decades
and decades and decades the first
spend less than you make it's that
simple if you spend more than you make
you can't make good financial decisions
if you spend less than you make you
have money to invest to save to to make
good sound financial decisions so
spend less than you make the second is
have multiple streams of income
don't be dependent on a single one a
bunch of people just got the crash
course on the idea
they had one stream of income their job
they lost their job they now they have
no income
if you have multiple streams of income
and you spend less than you make that
will solve
a very high percentage of your financial
problems
multiple streams of income say uh spend
less than you make
the third thing that they do is that
they have a
very long time horizon and that long
time horizon
comes with a lot of discipline and then
the fourth rule
is to simply get out of cash and get
into real assets
so that you can benefit from inflation
rather than be punished by it
it's not that hard if you can get out of
cash and you can get into
investable assets you will see the price
of those investable assets increase in
price over long periods of time because
inflation will inflate the value of that
asset
and so that's the game spend less than
you make have multiple streams of income
have a very long time horizon and be
disciplined
and then simply get out of cash and get
into investable assets and let the
market structure take advantage
or go to work for you that's it that's
the whole game
and so i think that now what we're
starting to see is people are
digging into and say okay i got it i'm
going to spend less than i make i got
multiple streams of income i want to
start investing
what should i look at and so earlier
this year i wrote a piece and i
basically broke down all the different
asset classes
and what we're seeing today is we're
seeing three separate things right or
three things that i personally think are
interesting
the first is bitcoin is the winner in
2020 right it has been
i've been saying this over and over and
over again i'm literally like banging my
head into the wall
keep saying this to people bitcoin is up
over 60
this year year-to-date so pre-pandemic
in january to today bitcoin is up 60
percent
it's not 60 off the bottom right it's up
60
year to date and why is that
interest rates got cut money got printed
and bitcoin is the only
approvally scarce asset in the world
so of course it is going to do well when
you are devaluing
an unlimited supply asset like the us
dollar
people are going to rush and they're
going to look for other types of assets
so bitcoin's done very well
gold gold has done well it's up 25 to 30
percent year to date
that means that gold went into the
crisis it
saw it draw down 12 to 15 and now has
recovered back to pre-pandemic levels
plus 25 to 30 percent why it is seen as
a
traditionally scarce asset i say
traditionally scarce
because the belief was that gold was
scarce what we are now seeing is when
you compare gold and bitcoin
gold actually is not scarce at all we
don't know what the total supply of gold
is we don't know what the circulating
supply of gold is
and we know that more gold can be made
through a chemical process or through a
scientific process
we also know that gold which is created
by stars
is very abundant in space
and so gold compared to bitcoin bitcoin
is provably scarce
gold is believably scarce there's a
difference there
but both of them are doing well because
people are rushing out of the dollar and
they're rushing into sound money or
inflation hedge type assets the third
asset equities when you have
assets that have drawn down right if you
take things like in
q2 lyft lost 60 of their revenue year
over year
when you look at something like
southwest airlines 80
of the revenue gone right these
companies have lost
so much that if you have deep conviction
in a specific type of company or a
specific sector
and you say i have a five or ten year
time horizon then you're able to buy an
asset today that has traded down because
the financial performance of it is down
now in many cases many of these
companies are actually overvalued even
though they're down off of their
all-time highs
right so if you all of a sudden buy a
stock that's down 20
percent but revenue is down 60 percent
you're still buying an over
priced asset because the company is not
actually worth only 20
off of thai it's actually worth 60
off its high maybe more and so you got
to be careful about just looking and
saying oh
pre-pandemic this stock is down 20
that's a discount i'm gonna go ahead and
buy it
you have to look at what is the
fundamentals of the asset today
when you're buying it and so in many
cases what you end up seeing is that
these assets are still overvalued
but people are buying them they're going
to continue as long as there continues
to be quantitative easing
you're going to see stocks in general
over a period of time
continue to be inflated because that is
what happens when you have quantitative
easing
then you move into things like real
estate
real estate is super interesting to me
for a couple of reasons
the first thing is uh one that you get
all sorts of commercial real estate so
commercial real estate in new york city
has been absolutely decimated
same with places in la san francisco
miami you know most major metros
when i walk down the street here in new
york city literally two
to four retail stores on every block
are they're done they're either shut
down they are shutting down
or they have signs up that say for lease
like this is a complete reset in the
retail commercial real estate uh market
in new york city
if you look at apartments there is more
empty apartments there's more inventory
on the market today
than ever before in new york and there
there's a whole reason behind it there
was this
a huge influx of international
investment capital that came in
builders saw that they started to build
aggressively by the time they actually
got the buildings built you know 18 to
36 months later
the investment capital had dropped off
so there was already kind of a bunch of
inventory
then you slap on the pandemic a bunch of
people fleeing the city
and so now you end up having all this
inventory uh with very little demand
and so prices start to drop then you
look at
residential real estate the median home
price has gone up why housing shortage
demand
increase uh because of uh cheap capital
and so you're naturally going to see
that
going up my guess is that we will
continue to see the trends in real
estate that we're seeing today
accelerate over the coming months now i
don't know what's gonna happen in five
or ten years right
i do believe businesses will go back i
do believe commercial real estate will
kind of regain its footing i do believe
that we will see
retail uh real estate also
come back now with that said where are
the opportunities in real estate
i think one cloud kitchens very very
interesting two
all sorts of warehouses very interesting
in terms of being able to service
e-commerce hubs or delivery hubs
the third thing is malls i do believe
that we are going to see
i'm sure many people saw the news with
amazon trying to basically take over
department stores and use them as
kind of these uh these warehouses or
e-commerce
uh delivery points i think what would be
very interesting is for somebody to
basically
buy out a uh an old mall that's been
suffering so you buy it at a discount
and then you basically built rebuild it
and re-imagine the idea
of a walkable city right you can imagine
if you get the right type of real estate
you could literally build a new type of
walkable city uh within the mall
infrastructure so real estate's super
interesting to me
uh and then lastly something i've been
paying more attention to is the art
market
so one of the details that a lot of
people don't know about uh when it comes
to
the super wealthy i'm not talking about
you know millionaires or
multi-millionaires
i'm talking about people that are worth
billions of dollars usually
a material part of their net worth is in
the art market
so leon black david geffen etc they
usually have you know
somewhere around 20 to call it you know
10 to 30 percent
of their net worth in in the private art
market and so what is that again
it is a scarce asset that serves as a
great inflation hedge
and they're simply getting exposure in
the private market where there's a lot
of dislocation and lack of efficiency
right there's no order book and what
they end up doing is end up making a lot
of money that way
and so ultimately what we continue to
see
from rich person to rich person to rich
person is they own
equity they own alternative assets
and they simply allow the market
structure the idea that the dollar is
going to be devalued over time
to work in their favor they position
themselves
to benefit and not to suffer from that
inflation from that quantitative easing
of trillions of dollars
if you sit in cash and you simply keep
getting paid paycheck to paycheck
with no investable assets your
purchasing power is going to get
destroyed
over the next three to five years it
will get destroyed
and so you have to protect yourself and
protecting yourself isn't just go by
bitcoin
it is simply getting in a position where
you can keep enough cash
for a rainy day whatever that number is
for you some people that may be one
paycheck
some people that may be three months
that may be six months whatever your
number is
where you feel comfortable having your
rainy day cash
everything else you got to go invest and
if you do it correctly
and you have a long time horizon the
asset prices will continue to increase
because of inflation
so i'm gonna start taking questions here
in a second before i do that
a couple of housekeeping items one smash
the like button that thumbs up
hit that button so more people on
youtube can find this content
two make sure you subscribe to the
channel three i write a daily letter
every single morning to over 50
000 investors please please please
subscribe i'm gonna drop the
um uh the url right now in the chat
uh if you subscribe i write about this
stuff every single day
absolute no-brainer uh also
if you want drop your questions and now
i'm gonna start answering as many of
these as i can
so let's go what um
always thought that it would be cool to
make old malls and living quarters and
apartments
yeah this is a no-brainer so my whole
idea here is if you think of what a city
is a city basically has
a living space it has retail space
uh and then it kind of has outdoor areas
parks all that kind of stuff
that's essentially what a mall is on a
smaller scale so you could literally
take the department stores turn them
into apartment buildings
right um you can take all of the retail
stores continue to have those
uh operate as retail or kind of consumer
endpoints so you could have everything
from food to shopping
all of that stuff right there and then
you basically take the surrounding
parking lot or parts of it and you
basically turn it into really nice
walkable parks or whatever and so to me
it's like a no-brainer to
go in buy very kind of depressed priced
malls uh or even um somebody may go in
and buy like an old university
property or something and go ahead and
turn that into
a a kind of mini city if you will
i think that'll become popular so we'll
see there um
let's see should the gold miners invest
in rocket ships so they can go to space
um yeah look people are obviously
becoming more and more aware of the idea
that yes gold exists in space
yes it is on asteroids uh ultimately
what ends up happening it's just
gold itself is actually created by stars
um and i think that uh people as they
kind of wake up to that
you know they like to joke around about
how do you go get the gold out of space
but yes that that is how
gold um is widely thought to uh to have
come into creation
how can we invest in commercial real
estate uh for newbies
coming from joseph uh look again i'm not
going to give kind of direct
kind of financial advice or anything but
i would say that
most people if they want access to some
sort of commercial real estate they'd
either do it through a reit structure
or some sort of financial vehicle where
they're not actually going out and
trying to buy the commercial real estate
themselves
um you know just it's expensive it's
time consuming you gotta go do the work
if you don't know what you're doing you
can buy
the bad asset all that kind of stuff um
but but if you go ahead and
actually just do it through some sort of
financial structure uh i think that
that's probably the most popular way
thoughts on the collectible cards market
as an inflation hedge
uh prices have been going through the
roof last few months uh yes
um so i know that a lot of people are
talking about and
investing in the trading uh sports card
market so whether it's basketball cards
baseball cards whatever it is
uh i've done um a little bit of work on
this i've talked to
a number of people who are some of the
biggest investors in the space from what
i understand
um and uh and they've been very gracious
with their time to uh to answer some
questions and
help me kind of just get up to speed in
terms of what's going on there
uh i personally have not actually bought
anything yet
uh i feel like there is a uh somewhat of
a learning curve
um that i just don't have an advantage
and so
uh i understand kind of why the market
is uh is going up
um there's a little bit of uh some of
the same things that happen
in crypto um but but just at this moment
i haven't bought anything yet
uh i do think it's interesting i do
think that um if you know what you're
doing and you're kind of disciplined
uh you can find good investments there
i've got a number of friends who who
have done pretty well
but it's just not something that i feel
like i have an advantage or some kind of
information
um that that uh makes sense for me so
that's kind of my take there
uh in your opinion what threat does
quantum computing pose to bitcoin in the
next five to ten years
uh i literally think quantum computing
is not a threat to bitcoin at all
uh one is as the computing power
increases so will the defenses to that
computing power
uh first of all second of all if you
have a quantum computer
um there's a lot of other things that
are likely to be attacked before bitcoin
in terms of getting state secrets all
that kind of stuff
third is if you attack bitcoin the game
theory then
suggests that you would destroy the
value of it so there's not really a way
to
uh financially profit from it and
therefore
uh it's kind of one of these things
where like maybe somebody gets
hold of a quantum computer that could
actually destroy the bitcoin network and
they
for some reason want to do that uh
without having financial gain
seems kind of unlikely maybe a state
actor but again i think that
we're pretty far away from that and also
um things can kind of become quantum
computing proof
um as that uh technology has also
developed so
not really uh too too worried about it
um
yeah so i see a lot of people talking
about scams they're seeing on the
internet
uh here's a quick um kind of uh
best practices if you will one is uh
never
ever ever ever ever send money uh or
bitcoin or ether or whatever
to an address under the promise that
somebody's gonna send you back more
that is a scam don't do it two is if
somebody communicates
with you on a social media platform
about sending them money
don't do it it's not that hard and what
you really want to do is you just want
to do your research
and make sure that you're not getting
scammed um
let's see what other questions what
other questions do we have here
uh do you think the situation now is a
bubble and a major correction is upon us
from tommy so i don't know necessarily
if this is actually a bubble
as much as the way that i think about
this is uh it's very clear
that there's trillions of dollars being
injected into the economy
uh that is inflating asset prices and
the big question right if somebody said
to me right now what's the most
important question
thinking about the economy and investing
is
can the government and the federal
reserve continue to inflate asset prices
long enough
for the economy to recover my guess is
they cannot and what i mean by that is
every time that they announce trillions
of dollars of monetary stimulus now
it's going to become less and less
effective and when with a thought that
oh this is only going to be a few weeks
kind of problem if you notice when they
set the program expiration dates
so the unemployment the additional
beefed up unemployment ended in july
the pvp money as long as you hold people
and you don't fire them until the end of
september then you can get a forgivable
loan
right all of that stuff was set to
expire kind of uh
in q3 give or take and so that's
basically when they thought that this
was all going to be over there was no
way we could get to this point right
there's kind of going to be this uh you
know four to six week lockdown
we were gonna get rid of the virus and
then we're gonna move on and in order to
bridge that gap right they call this
bridge
the gap stimulus they set up those
programs
well obviously here we are in august and
that stimulus has one not bridge the gap
because we still have
the public health crisis we still have
lockdown so we still have the mask
mandates right we in some places we sell
shelter at home all that kind of stuff
and so they either have to one allow
that stuff to run off and then we have
to deal with the economic realities that
are underlying it because there's no
kind of
um inflection or injection of liquidity
or two they can do another injection of
liquidity and what they're trying to
negotiate right now
is another injection uh the problem is
the republicans only want to do one
trillion dollars
democrats want to do three trillion
dollars uh and they literally are acting
like little kids
who can't come to a compromise and so uh
most people who are paying attention
know this but if you're not paying
attention they're not even negotiating
right now
they're literally both sitting on their
hands staring at each other saying well
i'll come to the table when you
pre-agree
to xyz and that's just not how you get
things done and so
unfortunately we've got a bunch of
politicians acting like children and
while they're acting like children that
ends up meaning that the american people
are the ones who suffer
right and so literally the tens of
millions of americans who lost their
jobs recently
if you were trying to get unemployment
you don't have that additional beefed up
unemployment insurance
there's a lot of things that kind of
aren't happening because we have
politicians who are frankly just being
little kids
so that's the that's the problem um
let's see here what other questions
uh do i think that depositing stable
coins on a crypto exchange that offers
interest returns is a good idea
um so i'm an investor in block fi
obviously uh they offer up to 8.6
apy on their interest bearing account
for stable coins
uh for those that don't know the way
that this works is uh when you deposit
dollars in your bank
your bank takes those dollars and they
lend it out sometimes with leverage so
they could lend it out five six seven
eight times
uh they earn interest off those loans
they then take a portion of that
interest and they pay you
that's the interest you earn in the
account and the bank takes the spread so
let's say they get paid three percent
they give you 0.05 percent they take the
spread
uh you get 0.05 in your kind of checking
account
uh and they and they take the difference
now the thing is that there's risk
associated with that and so there's fdic
insurance
uh to give you the peace of mind to
deposit up to 250 000
and even if the bank screws up or the
loan goes bad basically the government
or fdic
insurance will assure you up in crypto
there's no such thing as fdic insurance
today
and so they're doing the exact same
thing you deposit uh a stable coin or
cryptocurrency they take it they lend it
out
uh they earn interest and then they come
back and they share a portion of that
interest with you
most of the crypto lenders are sharing a
majority uh with the
depositors um and then taking a small
spread for themselves so kind of the
the different approach whereas in the
legacy world the bank takes majority
and the depositor gets a very small
percent here the depositor is getting
majority and the
the um you know organization that's
providing the software to do that
they're taking a small percent now the
difference there's still risk right just
like in the banking system there's just
no fdic insurance
and so you got to make sure you do your
own research understand how it works
but what i also tell people is like
don't go put 100 of your money into an
interest-bearing account
right don't do that in the legacy
finance system and also don't do that
in the crypto system either so i put
about i can't remember exactly but
somewhere in like the 10 to 15 percent i
think
uh range in terms of uh how much um
you know i've kind of allocated to
interest bearing accounts so it's a
material percentage but
uh it's not like if something goes wrong
then all of a sudden i would lose
uh kind of all of uh all of my assets
there so that's kind of how i think
about it i generally think
uh you know don't listen to what i say
just kind of watch what i do i've got 10
15 percent
uh and uh i basically think of it that
way
do i think the us dollar will ever have
a valuable backing again
no i don't i know that there's a lot of
people who believe we can return to a
gold standard
i think frankly that that is a complete
dream i do not see this ever going back
to the gold standard
and mainly it's because we've got a
government that now is addicted to
uh their ability to control manipulate
the economy right if you remember
in 1971 and 72 when we decided to go off
the gold standard it was tech
it was technically a temporary measure
we were temporarily going off the gold
center but we were going to go back
and then we just never went back and so
once you get
kind of a taste of the power and the
control
that you have in printing money and
quantitative easing or tightening
then all of a sudden what you see is uh
there's no desire to go back right there
there's nobody in uh in congress or in
the government that's pounding the table
saying we have to go back to a gold
standard
in fact they're saying the exact
opposite they're saying we need to print
more money we need to cut interest rates
or we need to go negative
um and so i think that generally humans
suck at
understanding what we're um you know the
fact that like we shouldn't do things
sometimes
right one of the the flaws of humanity
is we feel like the only way to have
control over a situation is to do
something
sometimes it might actually be better
not to do anything at all but because
we've gotten that taste of that i don't
think we'll ever go back
uh to a gold standard do i think that
the u.s dollar be pegged to bitcoin
absolutely not uh i think what's much
more likely is that bitcoin just
ultimately
uh increases um kind of a market cap
standpoint eventually assumes the role
of global reserve currency uh it does
that without any country actually kind
of putting the stamp of approval
it's just the people start using it um
as a cross-border currency or native
currency to the internet
and there you go you end up seeing
um exactly what uh what what you can do
there
uh do i see some kind of fed coin
actually happening uh absolutely i think
that we'll see a digital dollar in the
next 24 months
um i think we'll also see a digital euro
digital yen a digital you know whatever
um and so i think that uh it's gonna get
to the point where every single currency
in the world will be digitized whether
that is a private currency like a libra
jpm coin or whatever uh every single
fiat government controlled currency will
be digitized
um so that's the digital dollar digital
wand whatever
and then also the decentralized
currencies are obviously digital as well
and so what that does is it removes any
competition at the technology layer
people aren't going to end up kind of
choosing a currency because of this
technology or that technology
most of them will basically be a feature
um
kind of parody right they all kind of do
the same thing where the competition
will exist is at the monetary policy
layer
so basically what is the monetary policy
of this currency and that's how i'm
going to choose whether i want to use it
or not and so ultimately that's where i
get the idea that i think
bitcoin specifically will uh will reign
supreme um
the the system that we have today
remember in the fiat system
if you are a saver you are punished and
if you are an investor you are rewarded
so we ask people to go to work every day
whether you're a fireman a teacher
a middle manager somewhere you work on a
in a manufacturing facility whatever it
is
we ask you to be great at your job do
your job and then when you go home
oh by the way we also need you to be an
investor
we need you to become a professional
investor to protect your wealth not to
make more money but just to protect your
wealth
because if you just sit with your cash
in your bank account you will lose money
over time you actually become
poorer over time even though you
actually
it says the same number in your bank
account
we can't have a system like that that's
how you get wealth inequality that's how
the rich get richer and the poor get
poorer
and the system that is a feature of the
system is not a bug of the system
wealth inequality is a feature of the
system and so the best way to do it is
to have a great reset
that great reset i believe is to go to
a fix supply asset like a bitcoin uh
where now all of a sudden all you have
to do is go to work be great at your job
when you get paid simply save your
currency you do not have to be an
investor
you can simply hold that currency and it
will continue to accrue value over time
because you did what you were supposed
to do you earned a living you spent less
than you made
and you simply saved right but in
today's fiat system savers are punished
investors are rewarded and therefore you
have to be good at your job and you have
to be a good investor
in the new system i believe that savers
will be rewarded and so that's where i
think that bitcoin itself will
become incredibly valuable um
yep i see jan saying uh you aren't even
beating inflation keeping your money in
the bank
that's the big problem um and so i think
we're seeing that on steroids right now
which is uh the wealthy they're
investing in assets uh
and uh frankly people who are less
fortunate they're sitting with cash
they're getting paid
paycheck to paycheck um and uh in many
cases that stimulus money is not being
invested they're simply holding on to it
they're spending it they're doing
whatever
um and so you got to get out of cash you
got to get into investable assets
make sure you get enough cash for a
rainy day but once you can get to that
point
then you got to start investing and
another kind of trick that the wealthy
understand
uh is pay yourself first so when you get
that paycheck before you pay your rent
before you do any of this stuff
pay yourself first make sure that you're
saving even if it's 100 bucks
a month right save the money and what i
mean by saving is you put it into an
investable asset
so whether you're buying stocks whether
you're buying a precious metal whatever
you want to do
do your own homework figure out what
your plan is but make sure that you
are not spending more than you make and
also
make sure that that money that you are
saving is not just sitting in cash you
need to put it to work
uh because if you don't inflation is
going to eat the hell out of it and
ultimately what this gets at is
again don't take my word for it multiple
federal reserve
uh folks now are talking about going
over the two percent uh target inflation
so for those that don't know this
uh the federal reserve basically has a
inflation target except two percent
uh they've only hit that three of the
last 10 years in terms of they've been
plus or minus within i think it's 20
basis points uh of that two percent so
they're not very accurate at hitting
that rate
um but now what they're talking about is
basically injecting so much liquidity in
the economy
that they can drastically uh increase
inflation right create a
highly inflationary environment and
allowing
the economy to overshoot the two percent
target before they ever do anything so
ultimately what happens is they believe
that they have such intimate control
over this system that they're going to
allow inflation to get over two percent
in the cpi official numbers
which means actually the bottom 20
percent or the bottom 40 percent of
americans are probably
be experiencing between 10 to 20
inflation right so if the
if the actual official number say two
percent
that means that the bottom 20 is
probably closer to 10
and if they overshoot it if they get to
two and a half three four percent
then all of a sudden the bottom 20 is
probably experiencing more than 10
some somewhere between 10 to 20
inflation so they are
literally talking about and openly
discussing the idea
that they are going to inflate away the
wealth they're going to steal the wealth
of the bottom 20 to 40
of americans simply to create a more
inflationary environment
so that we can continue to see asset
prices rise
they're literally talking if you hear
them talking about creating a highly
uh inflationary environment what they're
saying is we're going to take the wealth
from the poor
and we are going to inflate asset prices
and the rich are going to get richer
than the poor going to get poorer
of course that wouldn't be a very
popular strategy if they said that but
if you use big fancy words
like we're going to create a highly
inflationary environment we're going to
overshoot our targets before we ever
take any action blah blah whatever then
people just oh yeah whatever
you know the smart rich people are
talking no
time out when you create highly
inflationary environments you steal the
wealth of the bottom 20 to 40
of americans and you enrich the wealthy
so if you
are in the bottom 50 of americans 45
of americans own no stocks and 50 of
americans can't come up with 400
payment for an emergency if you're in
that group
you can't wait around for the government
or the federal reserve to do things to
protect your wealth that's not their job
the federal reserve's job is to manage
an economy it is not to protect you
as i always say you have to get educated
you have to look out for yourself
no one is going to look out for you like
you would look out for yourself and so
in order to protect yourself you have to
invest capital
you cannot get caught holding cash
because it's going to get eaten away so
you have to get
investment assets stocks precious metals
uh bitcoin real estate whatever you want
do your own research make your decision
but get into those assets
all right uh this is super good for
people with huge mortgages though of
course they're all
uh remortgaging or refining their uh
their homes
uh and they're trying to figure out all
kinds of different stuff um
let's see what else here uh
what else um send me your questions some
of your questions i'm gonna stick around
for another
15 minutes uh
uh when they do that uh oh when they
increase inflation they are also trying
to increase velocity of money
yes they're trying to increase velocity
of money the problem is that they have
no control over that velocity of money
meaning that they can create highly
inflationary environments
um but what ultimately occurs is uh just
because there's high levels of inflation
doesn't mean that velocity of money
actually returns
and what you end up seeing is that
certain or
uh groups of people have high
psychological damage
uh or scarring because they're the ones
who just lost their jobs they're the
ones who actually just got hurt the
worst
and so then they get caught in this
mindset right if you think back to 2008
2009
there's an entire generation of people
who literally
got most of their wealth crushed
in 2008 2009 that were older and so if
you were a baby boomer
you maybe got wiped out by 2008 2009
you're about probably 50
right 50 to 60 years old now all of a
sudden you look and you say wait a
second
so they had a severe significant
financial situation and right when
coming out of the 2008 2009 crisis let's
call it sometime between 2012
13 is when they kind of started to say
okay maybe we're recovering
but they were really really close to
their chest with assets from
uh the the bottom of the markets called
209 2010 until like 13 14
into 15. and then right as baby boomers
started saying okay you know what i
think that market's back and they
started to invest
they started to invest at the top of the
market and they started to invest more
and more and more and more
into 17 18 and 19 and then in 2020
when we had the pandemic the pandemic
related
drop in the stock market there's a bunch
of data coming out now that shows
the people who sold their stocks at the
bottom of the market were the oldest
generation
why they have the shortest timeline they
thought that it was gonna take
such a long period of time for the uh
stock market to come back
so they basically said i'll take a 30
haircut on my assets i'd rather have the
cash now
then lose 50 percent and right when they
sold those assets banned the market
recovered
and so they should have just held it but
because their age the lack of time
they were forced to make decisions when
they made those decisions it was
a kind of 10 to 15 year trend so
those people got hurt in 2008 2009 they
stayed close to their chest
with their assets they were very stingy
they didn't do a lot of investing they
missed a majority of the bull market
that we've had over the last decade
and then right near the top kind of 17
18 19
they started to really get comfortable
again remember oh these are the good
times they started to invest invest
invest
bam stock market gets crushed as soon as
stock market gets crushed they sell
their assets they got a short time
period
and now the market recovers so they
basically have gotten shaken out of
their wealth almost
twice in the last 12 to 13 years
absolutely incredible people aren't
talking about it but there's an entire
generation of people
who fell victim to the one thing in the
world which is don't react to short-term
price movements but that's what happened
all right um what else what else what
else do i think institutions will buy
bitcoin or a bitcoin derivative like
uh i don't know uh gbtc i think that's
what's supposed to say
uh how does that affect prices uh for
the most part uh institutions were not
involved in bitcoin whatsoever
um until let's call it you know 2019
2020
and yes there were some institutions
here and there who put small amounts of
money in but for the most part
uh there was no real institutions i'm
talking about institutions with hundreds
of billions of dollars
uh to play with and so what you saw was
retail
industry the retail investors retail
holders they
built and created a 200 billion market
cap asset
now gold is eight nine trillion dollars
whatever it is some people think it's
ten trillion dollars you know whatever
the number is so
let's just use eight trillion as the
number if you look at
bitcoin it's at a 200 billion dollar
market cap which means that it would
have to what is that
40x uh no i'm sorry uh yeah 40x it had
to 40x
to get to gold's market cap institutions
will help drive that
right and ultimately what i think you're
going to see is you're going to see
institutions realize that gold is
or that bitcoin is superior to gold and
we're going to surpass the gold market
cap
so just that alone i don't know how long
that takes right but
institutions are going to be helpful in
doing that i do i don't think retail
investors
and kind of retail holders can push us
up to kind of the levels of the gold
market cap so you're going to need
institutions to come in
the good news is that institutions just
like individuals are paying attention
like wait a second
i'm exposing myself to inflation i can't
just sit in cash
and therefore they're looking for
inflation hedge assets bitcoin has
become a more popular option
whether that's somebody like a paul
tudor jones coming out saying wait i
need inflation hedge assets i think
bitcoin will be the fastest horse
i'm going to go ahead and invest there
or that is um you know we've got two
public pensions
uh at morgan creek that uh that have
anchored our funds um that have
basically said hey look we think this is
super interesting
disruptive innovative um and potentially
can create some value so we wanna get
exposure
uh to also now you're starting to see
groups like renaissance technology
uh put into some of their regulatory
filings they want to be able to trade
this stuff
uh you see fidelity setting up an entire
digital business like this stuff's not
going away
and it's not going to be less valuable
in five or ten years than it
uh it is today it's only going to get
more valuable only more people are going
to get interested in it right and so i
think that ultimately you're going to
see institutions come in you'll see
institutions come in in a big way
and i think that'll have a very material
impact on the price
what happens and what time frame how
much of a impact
that's for everyone to debate but i do
think that that is uh
what we are what we're starting to see
there um
all right what uh what other oh before i
forget make sure you smash the like
button right now so that more people on
youtube can find this content
super important that thumbs up button
right under the video make sure you hit
that button
uh subscribe to the channel and then i
am putting
a url right now in the chat
pompletter.com again p-o-m-p
pompletter.com i write a email every
single morning to
uh over 60 000 investors now um all
about
the business finance the economy bitcoin
etc
so make sure you go get and subscribe to
pompletter.com and
you can get that content every single
morning uh
okay let's talk presidential election is
biden a good choice for bitcoin uh or tr
uh and obviously trump uh look i don't
think that either one
is going to matter and what i mean by
that is most politicians are exactly the
same they make big promises and they
don't fulfill them right
at the end of the day that's what it
boils down to obviously trump has taken
a really strong stand against china
if you look at somebody like biden he
probably won't be nearly as strong
against it
uh if you look at kind of what they're
both looking for the republican party in
general wants to spend less money
uh the democratic party want is okay
spending kind of more money
um ultimately i don't think it's going
to matter right if you look at
the the last six fiscal years in the
united states we have collected
more income tax revenue every single
year for six years
so the the income or the revenue of the
government is going up
but at the same time the deficit is
going up which means that they are
increasing their spending faster than
they're increasing their revenue
it's a bad business model right but what
ends up happening is they keep taking
more money from you and i
uh ultimately for bitcoin i don't think
it's gonna matter
i don't think that there's any sort of
ban of bitcoin or anything like that
gonna happen
uh it is a fully decentralized system
that can't be shut down and i think what
you're going to end up seeing is you're
going to end up seeing
um either one of those people step in
there's going to be a lot of spending
right republicans want to spend a
trillion dollars democrats want to spend
3 trillion
uh it's going to continue to devalue the
dollar weaken the dollar you're gonna
see people fleeing for inflation hedge
assets still over the next kind of two
to three years
um and things like bitcoin gold real
estate and even stocks of some degree
uh will continue to uh to kind of
benefit from that but that's not a
political thing that's not
you know somebody is a president and
therefore that's the impact on the
market
the bigger structural kind of more
important uh trend is the fact that the
federal reserve
uh understands that the united states
economy is now addicted to monetary
stimulus we have to have a low rate
environment
and we have to have massive amounts of
monetary stimulus if we don't have that
quantitative easing
literally the economy gyrates and and
will break
and so i don't think that we're going to
see us coming out of a zero rate
environment for a long period of time
and i do think that we'll see uh for
sure in 2020 another
uh very large monetary stimulus package
you know again i've kind of pegged it at
uh over two trillion dollars for sure um
and
then we'll see what happens in 2021 uh
let's
see
[Music]
let's see here any advice on getting
into a career in tech investing with an
econ and finance background
a lot of people don't know this i
actually have an economics degree
and then obviously on the tech side
daniel so here's three tips
that i always tell people when it comes
to jobs uh one it's who you know two
it's the work part of you created
and three is uh it also comes down to
what you're willing to do
uh to get in in the door and so what i
mean by that is one who do you know uh
things like twitter are incredibly
valuable on the tech investing side
right so
uh being able to uh learn what are these
people talking about what are they
focused on
what have they invested in all that kind
of stuff two is you also can communicate
with them so you're able to
tweet at them you're able to dm them all
that kind of stuff so someone's
who do you know two is what can you do
right or what have you done
uh i think resumes are stupid at this
point right so if you want to get a job
in tech investing here's what i would do
i would literally go and i would say all
right what
are the investment themes that i think
are interesting um let's say that i
decided uh 3d manufacturing was going to
be interesting because we're gonna have
to reshore a bunch of
manufacturing and supply chains and
therefore 3d manufacturing is going to
play a big part in that
to keep the labor costs down and to
continue to kind of drive efficiency
while
improving the resiliency of a business
so that's my overarching theme
i'm going to find a bunch of 3d
manufacturing businesses i'm going to
talk to the ceos or talk to people at
the companies i'm going to read
as much as i can i'm going to create
investment memos on
let's say the five best companies uh and
then i'm also going to write a three to
five page summary of the 3d
manufacturing industry
right now why would i do all that work
because then i'm going to turn around
and i'm going to literally send it to
every single tech
investor that i know and i'm going to
say hey i don't know i have never
worked at a tech investment firm i've
got an economics and a finance degree
i think that this is super interesting
though i'd love to break into the
industry
in order to show what i'm capable of
i've gone out i've researched a sector
i've written a thesis on why this sector
should be a positive place to focus on
in the future
and on top of that i've gone out and i
found the five most interesting
companies i could find
and i wrote an investment thesis on all
five of them here's the information
feel free to use it even if i don't get
the job just thought you would find it
interesting if you've got
uh opportunities on your team please let
me know and i'd love to have a
conversation
you will get more meetings that way than
sending a resume absolutely
and what you'll be able to do is you'll
be able to prove the quality of your
work and so if you're good
people will jump they'll literally you
know they'll compete over each other to
hire you
if you're not good then they won't and
so ultimately what it comes down to is
just what's the body of work that you
can do
so can you get in touch with people can
you communicate with them can you build
relationships
and then what is the actual quality of
the work um and so i think that being
able to showcase that work right if you
said to me hey i want to be a salesman
um you know at a software company i'd
say great you should show up to the
interview
and you should have three leads for them
and those leads you should have already
talked to the companies and said to them
hey i'm going for an interview at this
company i think it would be super
interesting
if i can get someone from their team to
jump on the phone with you would you
guys take the meeting
and if the prospect says yes then great
you go to the meeting and literally i
would bring a piece of paper and i would
say hey
you know i really want to be a salesman
here but before we start the meeting
i've already done the work
i've already been able to prospect three
leads those three leads here's all the
information that i have on them and
here's the individual and the contact
information of the people who
at that company would like to take a
meeting with you well now it's not a
question of can you do the job you
already did the job you proved you could
do the job before you even had the job
so of course
they're going to be interested in
potentially hiring you so you can use
that same mechanism over and over again
uh depending on what the role is that
you're looking to go get
and then in terms of the last point is
just what are you willing to actually do
many people want to come in they want to
be a partner on day one right they want
to be the head of sales on day one
but look at the end of the day if you're
young if you don't have experience in an
industry you got to eat [ __ ] for a while
and that's not a bad thing right that's
how you learn
and so i think that you've just got to
be able to be humble enough to say look
i'll do whatever you guys want right
whatever you need
for the better kind of good of the team
i'm here i want to work you know
put me to work and doing whatever the
tasks are that you need
and what you find is by having that
mentality and being able to be
successful and doing whatever the team
needs
they'll keep giving you more
responsibility so if you're if you're
end up uh being successful at task one
then they give you a second task then a
third test then a fourth test and a
fifth one
and every time it gets a little bit
bigger a little bit more important a
little bit more
intricate and complex and i think that's
really what you eventually want to get
to is you want to be able to
get to the point where uh they know hey
if we give him something to do
uh or her or something to do then
they'll just get it done
so that uh that makes sense um
this dude could sell kias i can sell
anything man it's not that hard to sell
all you gotta
understand is i'm trying to solve
somebody else's problem of course um
let's see here uh what do i think about
dave portnoy getting in the game
uh look dave portnoy is uh is a star
obviously um he understands uh
exactly how media works he saw this way
before
most people he's built an incredible
company you know back in march 2017 i
wrote a piece when the company was
valued at 15 million dollars
and i said this is going to be a billion
dollar business they're at 450 million
today i have no doubt that it's gonna be
a billion dollar business
uh ultimately they've got a highly loyal
and engaged fan base
he really really has his pulse on kind
of what the audience wants um they
continue to make bold
uh bets uh that pan out right they just
signed dion sanders
uh from the nfl network so things like
that i think you gotta be bold you gotta
be innovative you've gotta be willing to
disrupt yourself
a little bit uh in order to continue to
grow and there uh both him and erica
nardini are willing to do that
uh i saw today the video you know i
tweeted and said laugh out loud funny
uh seeing cameron tyler and dave all
talking about bitcoin
um you know it's ultimately a good thing
right i i tend to think awareness is uh
is pretty important uh i thought cameron
tyler did a great job
uh explaining bitcoin to uh to dave and
uh
look once you get some skin in the game
like dave has now looks like he bought
kind of six figures worth of bitcoin
um you start paying attention and so
we'll see kind of how it plays out but i
think that uh
naturally it's a pretty uh uh pretty
positive thing
pomp would you invest in a
pseudo-anonymously run company
i've talked to a few founders that
basically aren't
using their real names i
personally have no problem with it when
we think about it from a
an institution or a fund level uh it
becomes a little bit harder
uh especially because we have things
like public pensions and audits and
things like that
um so still trying to figure that one
out but uh i
i do think that um it's pretty cool to
see and
you know look kind of a thread on this
is
uh i believe that decentralization is
going to become absolutely essential so
if you look at things like tick tock
if tick tock had decentralized
infrastructure and decentralized
ownership
there wouldn't be a conversation right
now about banning it um but obviously
that there's centralization and
therefore there's that threat
um i think that decentralization is
going to be uh important not only for
money
for the financial system uh for
organizations for uh you know what would
have been corporations all that kind of
stuff
i also believe um that pseudony uh
pseudonymity i guess
um and anonymity is going to become um
a great advantage i don't think it's
necessarily going to become essential
but i do think that people who are able
to whether it's create content do things
and do it soon anonymously they will uh
eventually end up actually having
a uh advantage in certain cases and so
definitely two things that i am uh i'm
interested in
is uh one the uh the decentralization
and then two
is the the pseudonymity or uh anonymity
um all right i'm going to uh stick
around for uh for two or three more
minutes what uh
what else say my investor at bank to the
future no i am not
uh any thoughts on crypto and real
estate market i already kind of touched
on that so just go back and watch the
video
um in my head worried about having a d5
bubble
yeah listen you got to be kidding me
with uh
this stuff i haven't paid super super
close attention but like the yams and
all this kind of stuff
um it's one of these situations where
ultimately what we're seeing in d5 today
is uh
is two uh trends right the first is
there's a lot of technology
being built there's not a lot of
products being built what i mean by that
is everyone's trying to basically
impress each other with oh look what i
made the technology do
but the products aren't usable for a
mass audience and therefore
uh you're gonna have to get another
iteration right that's not gonna say a
bad thing you have set to be able to
build the technology first
and then you gotta be able to build a
usable product on top of it but right
now we're still in the technology phase
so lots of people are building all this
kind of crazy stuff
and if you're really really committed if
you're really interested in the stuff if
you're technical
you can go and you can play with all the
intricacies of it but they're not usable
products so
for the most part is technology it's not
a product you got to get to products in
order to get adoption
the second thing is there's a lot of
financial engineering so if i go and i
take
you know money and i put it into a cdp
and i take out you know
some high percentage of a collateralized
loan and then i go and i put in a second
cdp and do it again and again and again
like that's not really anything other
than financial engineering
and so when you look at a lot of these
things uh again that's not necessarily a
bad thing there's plenty of financial
engineering that goes on the legacy
markets or whatever
but but it's just kind of you gotta call
it what it is and so uh
is that a bubble is it not i don't know
i haven't paid enough attention to know
like are we at the top of the bubble
uh but i definitely think that things
obviously are frothy
um and when things get frothy uh there's
usually some kind of corrections right
and so
um i don't know if comparing it to the
ico bubble in uh 16 to 17
is fair um but but i do think that um
that there's a kind of a lot of
talk and excitement but i don't think
i've necessarily seen the products yet
that that
can kind of fulfill that not a bad thing
just kind of my assessment of it and so
uh i think over time though you will see
um
a lot of decentralized finance
applications right
bitcoin is a defy application you'll see
a bunch of them get built
uh and the world needs them so you know
all good
on that front um
did i go to college yes i went to
bucknell university and uh i got an
economics degree
um hey pop do you think putting 50 net
worth into bitcoin is too much i just
started working one and a half years ago
it's not much money on the sidelines for
sure my
for sure emergency money excluded uh
yeah again look i can't give financial
advice
uh what i can tell you is what i did i
did 50 um
in december of 2018 i think it was
um and uh my whole thought process was
just
i picked a number that i was willing to
lose and
not lose sleep over but at the same time
would have a material impact if things
went well
as many people know i don't really
believe in diversification
i'm a big believer in high conviction
bets with concentration
i'm also young i'm 32 years old so i've
got quite a bit of time ahead of me in
terms of if something goes wrong
but that's just kind of how i thought
about it i usually tell people
for most part people if you want to
invest in bitcoin
i would say the uh the most popular
percentages i see are still like one to
five percent
uh they kind of look at it as like a
risk asset um
so i think that's uh that's kind of how
i look at allocation
um all right two more questions let's go
what do we got here
uh are financial institutions like banks
going to use bitcoin of course the occ
announcement
uh just made it okay for them to custody
bitcoin um
we just saw uh microstrategy the
publicly traded nasdaq companies 1.2
billion
market cap they took 250 million dollars
off their balance sheet and they bought
bitcoin
i think you're going to see a lot more
of that kind of as a reserve asset or
treasury reserve asset
um and i think that uh absolutely you're
going to see that
with banks just as much you're going to
see with every other company as well
so i think that is uh it makes a lot of
sense
um let's see
how is married life that's a good one to
uh and done married life is great
paulina and i are having a lot of fun uh
we actually
i think it was uh one month uh on the
11th
so uh the first month down uh got no
complaints
i think um you know we're excited it's a
little weird to get married during the
pandemic uh it's a little weird to not
really kind of be able to celebrate with
all your friends and family
um but uh but so far so good we're
enjoying it and uh
if you got wedding advice then uh email
me dm me whatever you got tweet at me
i'll take all the advice i got because
uh you know never done this before so uh
that should be good
but all right i'm losing my voice so i
got to get the hell out of here
uh before i do that a couple of
housekeeping items smash the like button
that thumbs up please please please hit
that thumbs up so that more people on
youtube can find this content
make sure that you're subscribed to the
channel i just dropped
in the chat a url that url
is to pompletter.com every single
morning so here's the deal on the pomp
letter
uh every single morning i wake up i go
through the news i pick a topic that i
think is
interesting and worth talking about and
then i basically write my personal
opinion i break down the topic
sometimes they're super long sometimes
they're short but i try to
basically say here's what happened in
the situation here's my personal
perspective on it here's why i think
it's important here's what i think is
going to happen
so that can be everything from asset
prices to markets to looking at
individual companies
um to things like bitcoin whatever it is
business
economy finance and bitcoin
please please go subscribe
pompletter.com
uh i really enjoy doing it it's awesome
when people email back and kind of share
their opinion as well
so pompletter.com go do it
smash the like button subscribe to the
channel and i will see you guys
later